hello freak [ __ ] if you care about
what you do that's just part of the
probe salutely and that's it there's a
healthy part to that and then like
moving on from it is it's easier now
than it used to be it was just like it
would live in me for a while oh dude you
forgot the worst of that song and then
it becomes a mental block you get up
there and you go oh [ __ ] like a you know
like a kicker or something you know the
guy going to kick a field goal is like
oh I missed that one I can't believe I
did then the next one oh my god now it's
a thing yeah oh so getting all those
metal boss yeah fighters lose a fight
and then they come back and then you can
see the discomfort you can see the
confusion and the fear and that's a
that's one of the hearts I think
psychological issues are some of the
hardest issues that people ever overcome
and it's just literally like a pattern
of thought in your mind right you just
decide that you're not as good as you
used to be you can manifest that like
physically you can do all the same
things that is so crazy the power of
thought the power of my mind is it's
pretty dangerous at times and being
creative I make up all kinds of crap you
know like a large is doing that just to
[ __ ] with me I know it and then you talk
with him laters like what are you
talking about whatever what yeah that's
that's pretty it's it's a curse and a
gift that creativity you know how hard
was it for you to get sober huh fear was
a big motivator in that for me you know
losing my family was that was that was
the thing that scared me so much that
was the bottom I hid that my family's
going to go away because of my behaviors
that I brought home from the road I got
kicked out of the house by my wife I was
living on my own somewhere and I you
know I did not want that and maybe as
part of my upbringing
you know my family kind of disintegrated
when I was a kid you know father left
mother passed away had to live with my
brother and then kind of just all like
the family you know where my stuff go
where
it just kind of floated away and I do
not want that happening you know no
matter what's going on we're going to
talk this stuff out make it work you
know my wife's of the same same idea
same thought that you know her family
she was the invisible kid too you know
so we relate a lot so there's no way
we're gonna let you know any argument
get in the way or just you know we're
survivors we're survivors and we're
gonna we're gonna talk through it no
matter how much and you know she she did
the right thing she kicked my ass right
the hell out of the house you know and
um that scared the [ __ ] out of me
so and she said hey you're not just
going to the therapist now and it's not
talking about this you got to go
somewhere and sort this [ __ ] out so
that's what I did though rehab did rehab
really worked for me telling Jeff to go
for uh well what worked for me was seven
weeks some place like basically tearing
you down to bones ripping your life
apart anything you thought about
yourself or what it was anything you
thought you had your family your career
your anything gone strip you down to
just okay you're born here's how you
were when you were born you're okay
you're a good good person let's get back
to that again and then they slowly
rebuild you and then I went to another
they call them aftercare places I went
there to a couple different ones and
they fine-tuned stuff and get you
integrated back into life because when
you're in this cocoon and you're your
friggin raw I mean I was raw meat when I
came out and you can see it in that some
kind of monster movie I was pretty raw
still I didn't know what I could or what
I should or shouldn't do you know so the
the last place we went to was a place
that helps relationships so they got me
and my wife together and we'd CC people
separately and then come together and
talk about what we did and communication
friggin saved my life
saved our family and working through
that stuff so very grateful for my wife
she's the one that didn't ask for this
[ __ ] she walked through fire with me and
we walked out together stronger way
stronger than we ever would have been
before and you know my kids know my
story my kids know my struggles and they
respect that they respect me in a
different way I don't have to tell them
what to do all the time or just be like
I'm this it I can say sorry I can tell
them hey here's what happened when I did
that and you know I don't need to preach
to them they got their own stuff but now
they've now they goof with me I ruined
my trust with my family and now by some
miracle they are goofing with me it's
like dad shut up what do you get my come
on you know you're over blowing this
your way out of dad you're taking up way
too much space here okay so they help me
and I realized that there is help in a
loving way how long have you been sober
now
15 15 years did it start out when you
when you first started doing it did it
feel like as you broke through and you
you you know you went to therapy and you
got out of rehab and you're going
through this whole thing was there like
a shaky leg period where you're like man
I mean do I Know Who I am anymore
oh absolutely that was it that was that
is you know the power of the mind and
how you know here's how my life works
and to actually just completely throw
that away and start over it's like well
wait a minute Who am I without this I'm
a I can't talk to people I'm anxious I'm
shy I'm all of the stuff that I thought
booze was helping me with or you know
you know booze drugs women shopping
eating gambling you know there's so many
things that can manifest out there that
it all goes back to one core thing it's
like I don't I don't really know who I
am
so it took years and years and years to
figure out okay I like that that's part
of me and this is part of me the anger
the the though you know the quirkiness
the dork part of me all these little
things that make me I got a hug am I to
accept them you know and quit running
from them and pretending like I am some
immovable object on stage that's tough
and you know nothing can do you know
nothing can hurt me but inside you know
it's kind of a cliche saying you know
the harder that external shield the
softer the inside and the more
vulnerable and in balancing that you
know almost like you're concentrating so
much on the heart outside that you
ignore the inside totally totally and
then forget what I really want and then
you lose yourself in that other that
other person and yeah being in a band
certainly accelerated that you know
there's there was drink a drug and all
kinds of stuff just thrown at you all
the time and it starts off as a fun
little thing and then it turns into a
sin escape and then all of a sudden you
don't really you don't remember why
you're out there doing stuff I went on
tour just so I could go to the strip
club hey we're going to this place you
know and we're going to drink here and
you know knew all that stuff but the
actual playing on stage it kind of got
forgotten about a little bit you know it
was we get caught up in the rock star
stuff and there's a there's a song on
this album called moth into flame that
directly talks about the how Fame can be
this crazy drug and it can completely
take you over if you let it you know
you're searching for that thing that's
going to save you and it's it's you it's
in you it's already there you just got a
you just got to find it and and accept
it
[Music]